[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos al diario de copas el
programa de france 24 en el que
analizamos la actualidad de la eurocopa
y la copa américa a continuación los
titulares
la selección de brasil venció a perú con
marcador de 4 goles por 0 y mantiene su
puntaje perfecto en la presente edición
de la copa américa de su técnico tea
puso en la mira a rivales europeos
tenemos reacciones y análisis
kevin de bruyne inspirador el jugador
del manchester city inglés vio el
triunfo de bélgica sobre dinamarca por
la segunda fecha del grupo b con la
victoria los 'diablos rojos' escribieron
su nombre entre los mejores del torneo
en breve detalles
portugal regresa a la acción los
actuales campeones se enfrentarán a
alemania mañana en el allianz arena de
múnich con el objetivo de sellar su pase
a la ronda de octavos en breve
comentarios y el ambiente en suelo
lusitano
brasil sigue como en pie y un paso
arrollador en la copa américa que
sustenta el buen momento del equipo que
dirige técnicamente y te para analizar
la segunda fecha del grupo b de esta
copa y otros temas relacionados con el
fútbol le doy la bienvenida a sara
castro directora del diario 'as'
colombia bienvenida hola luis un gusto
estar en este diario de copas con mucha
información y análisis y como ya lo
habíamos adelantado brasil volvió a
ganar con contundencia esta vez se
impuso a perú con un marcador de 4 goles
por 0 gracias a las anotaciones de
alecsandro
neymar júnior everton ribeiro y
richarlyson sara porque estamos viendo
esta amplia diferencia de brasil
respecto a otras selecciones de la
conmebol es una muy buena pregunta es
una pregunta interesante porque habla
del trabajo de mucho tiempo que ya lleva
ti está al frente de la selección
brasilera de una serie de jugadores de
una alta calidad técnica en primer lugar
y también de adaptación táctica que eso
no lo tienen muchos equipos y sobre todo
muchas variantes el problema que está
teniendo en este momento brasil es que
se mira a sí mismo está empezando a
sentir que no
competencia y empieza a dosificar el
juego ayer por momentos e incluso
aburrido en el primer tiempo preocupó un
poco porque no tiene esa continuidad los
90 minutos luego analizaremos como para
la segunda parte
neymar y everton rivero empiezan a
generar mucha más creatividad empezamos
a ver ese brasil más alegre al que
estamos acostumbrados por supuesto que
sí y eso que hablaba sé que parece
mirarse a sí mismo también es motivo de
preocupación para muchos de los medios
de comunicación escuchemos las
respuestas del seleccionador brasileño a
esta pregunta
estos rivales sudamericanos de las
competencias de la conmebol no son
suficientes para usted producir
el reportero es español y si se marca en
españa' gustaría españa nos gustaría
portugal
nos gustaría todas las elecciones
europeas si tuviésemos un calendario que
nos permitiera tener esas oportunidades
que nos proporciona bases también los
restauraciones la jornada inició con el
partido entre colombia y venezuela un
partido que terminó con un resultado
empate sin goles significando el primer
triunfo para el combinado venezolano y
el cuarto para la selección de
colombiana en el presente torneo sobre
este partido será a quien podemos darle
la virtud a colombia que intentó intentó
intentó en el ataque oa venezuela por su
defensa yo creo que primero hay que
hablar de la dignidad y concentración de
venezuela evidentemente lo poco que
podía hacer peseiro era poner un bloque
defensivo muy sólido intentando frenar y
escalonar tanto las bandas como el juego
por el centro de colombia y lo logró
hacer muy bien luego aparece una gran
figura
wilker fariñas que volvió a la titular
sacó ocho pelotas de gol y esto hace que
el partido
atípico en colombia creo que el volumen
ofensivo mejoro tuvo más llegada
evidentemente pues venezuela apenas
remató una vez al arco rival
pero le sigue faltando esas respuestas
tácticas para solucionar este tipo de
enredos no o sea hay mucha virtud
individual por ejemplo cardona fue muy
interesante en el primer tiempo poniendo
pases a la espalda de la defensa pero
colectivamente le falta en
funcionamiento la selección colombia
evidentemente este es el cuarto partido
de reinaldo rueda al frente del equipo
nacional así que creo que veremos ese
tipo de adaptaciones creo que le faltó a
colombia para poder definir tus opciones
muy claras y esa falta de eficacia en un
torneo como éste termina costando
hablaste de la figura de wil querer
fariñas vamos a escuchar qué fue lo que
dijo el jugador venezolano al concluir
este encuentro
fue un punto importante para nosotros a
pesar de las dificultades que hemos
pasado para esta continuación de copa
américa nos ha apostado por el tema de
de salud bueno esperemos que con el
favor de dios los muchachos se mejoren y
creo que este empate se lo debemos a
todo el equipo el sacrificio el esfuerzo
a los que nos están acompañando los que
nos están viendo desde casa desde desde
el hotel esto esto también es por
ustedes estamos aquí por ustedes pero el
confort de o podemos seguir mejorando
hoy habrá acciones por el grupo a la
primera hora chile se estará midiendo la
representación de bolivia mientras que
más adelante estará enfrentando
argentina a la representación de uruguay
pero vamos a pasar a la euro 2020 que
ayer presentó una jornada interesante
por el grupo c ucrania dio cuenta de
macedonia del norte dos goles por uno
mientras que países bajos superó a
austria toxo goles por 0 por el grupo p
bélgica dio cuenta de dinamarca con
marcador de 2 goles por 1 en un partido
donde estaban cayendo hasta el minuto 54
un gol por 0 sara vamos a hablar de
bélgica que importante es y seguirá
siendo kevin de bruyne para el conjunto
que dirige en español martínez en los
actuales momentos estamos hablando de
uno de los mejores mediocampistas del
mundo y no solo es bueno porque
individualmente le aporta en el tema
ofensivo sino que él entró y empezó a
frenar esa pérdida de balones en el
mediocampo de estructural es un jugador
que hace jugar mejor al equipo al
colectivo y eso es muy importante que es
lo que pasa con esta bélica parece que
le falta ese espíritu no es una serie de
grandes jugadores pero sin un alma
colectiva y parece que necesita de esos
estímulos como lo que encontró el
entrenador
incluida de bruijn para generar ese
cambio esa revolución interna el primer
tiempo dinamarca los puso en muchos
problemas también animado por ese
espíritu del estadio después del
homenaje a eriksen yo creo que eso
también apoya un poco a esta bélgica que
le cuesta eso no son jugadores un poco
aburguesados en su talento y que
necesitan encontrar esa chispa y de
bruijn es un jugador fundamental para
eso las jornadas del día de hoy ya está
rodando y comenzó muy temprano con el
partido entre la selección de suecia y
eslovaquia que terminó con un triunfo
para la representación sueca a esta hora
disputan su segundo partido las
representaciones de croacia y república
checa- y cerrará la jornada con un duelo
entre escocia e inglaterra mañana
regresará el accionar del grupo
considerado de la muerte y uno de los
partidos de las jornadas contempla el
enfrentamiento entre portugal y alemania
nuestra compañera daniela zambrano desde
portugal nos trae el siguiente reporte
un partido en el que sin duda alemania
llega con mayor presión que portugal
pues no acumula ni goles ni puntos tras
su derrota contra francia y que podría
significar para portugal
el actual campeón su pase a octavos de
final el partido se disputará este
sábado de múnich a las 5 de la tarde
ahora portugal las celebraciones en el
país estarán bastante limitadas por
causa de la pandemia incluso en la
cámara municipal de lisboa prohibió la
instalación de pantallas en sitios
públicos durante toda la eurocopa para
evitar aglomeraciones de personas dado
al aumento del número de casos de kobe
en las últimas semanas y que la
situación es calificada ya de
preocupante por las autoridades incluso
se aplicó una nueva restricción para
este fin de semana y que está prohibida
la salida y entrada desde y hacia el
área metropolitana de lisboa lisboa es
uno de los 10 municipios en portugal que
no avanza en la fase de confinamiento
que inició el pasado 10 de junio y
también hay otras localidades con ago
mayores restricciones como es el caso de
sesimbra que acumula en las últimas dos
semanas más de 240 casos por cada
100.000 habitantes
incluso los restaurantes y comercios
deben cerrar a las 3 30 de la tarde hora
local sin embargo los ciudadanos han
manifestado su apoyo a la selección
colocando banderas en sus apartamentos y
también en los comercios además de este
vuelo entre portugal y alemania también
en la jornada sabatina enfrentará a
hungría y francia y cerrará con el
choque entre españa y portugal
sara brevemente que podemos esperar de
este grupo llamado de la muerte donde
están dos campeones mundiales los
últimos y también el último campeón de
la euro yo creo que nos vamos a centrar
en ese partido entre portugal y alemania
estadísticamente alemania siempre ha
superado a portugal y en el primer
encuentro a los lusos les vimos algunos
problemas de generación y de creación
desde el mediocampo alemán ya tiene la
posesión necesita enlazar con ese
delantero y creo que va a ser un juego
mucho más parejo va a ser un juego
intenso y mañana por supuesto lo
estaremos analizando todo aquí en diario
de copas
a continuación revisamos una selección
de noticias de ambos torneos el jugador
danés christian eriksen fue operado con
éxito para implantarle un desfibrilador
que controlará su ritmo cardíaco y
evitará situaciones similares a la
vivida en el duelo entre dinamarca y
finlandia podría recibir el alta médica
este viernes
el mediocampista español sergio busquets
fue recibido con honores por sus
compañeros de selección luego de haber
dado negativo en un test psr el ficha
del barcelona no verá acción mañana
durante por frente a polonia pero el
director técnico luis enrique espera
darle minutos frente a eslovaquia
en brasil el director del instituto
butantán y más cobas calificó en una
entrevista ofrecida a la agencia de
noticias efe como una decisión
equivocada y sima el haber llevado la
copa américa a ese país además agregó
que esto podría tener consecuencias
para cerrar los dejamos con las imágenes
de ayuda el elefante del zoológico de
hamburgo en alemania quien anunció el
triunfo de la selección de su país
frente a portugal este sábado dicen que
los elefantes nunca olvidan algo se sabe
la ayuda que nosotros no sabemos
sara y tenemos que tomar el puesto va a
ser una jornada de mucho fútbol y mañana
muy pendientes para analizar cómo va a
hacer ese enfrentamiento entre dos
grandes selecciones por supuesto que sí
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
haber estado con nosotros sigan con más
de la programación de france 24 y
france24 puntocom
i